benito trevino est un homme qui murmure
à l'oreille des oiseaux celui ci en
particulier ce géo coucou que vous
connaissez peut-être mieux sous le nom
de runner fait partie du quotidien du
septuagénaire depuis des années tout
comme ces plantes typiques du texas vez
comme ses ancêtres venus cette année
d'ici beneteau trevino les cultivent les
protège et les transforment en divers
objets ce ranch
il a bâti avec sa femme toni né dans une
famille qui votent démocrate depuis des
générations
entrepreneur est devenu républicain il
affirme que les huit années de
présidence obama ont été pénibles
obama one action avec les hausses de
taxes et l'imposition de nouvelles
règles aux employeurs dit il
il nous était difficile d'embaucher des
travailleurs sous l'ère trempe
il assure que l'espoir est revenu qui la
gardait davantage d'argent dans son
porte-monnaie qu'il ait pu agrandir son
entreprise
dans la vallée du rio grande et une
région au taux de chômage plus élevé que
la moyenne du texas
le parti républicain a axé son message
sur l'économie et les emplois
donald trump a grugé l'appui dati nos
des démocrates dans cette région où la
population est d'origine hispanophone à
plus de 90%
ils ont été très courtisé par la
campagne du président cette observateurs
soulignent que bon nombre de latinos
très religieux partage plusieurs
positions des républicains par exemple
contre l'avortement
il se fût ce que d'entendre ceux qui
votent pour donald trump se fait à
traiter d'idiot ou accusée de manquer
d'amour propre
vu les propos du président sortant sur
les mexicains à la cause d'un contexte
de haut niveau de ce côté ci du rio
grande et longue frontière avec le
mexique et benito trevino souligne qu'il
a réussi en trimant dur à se sortir
d'une extrême pauvreté grâce si pauvre
qu'il n'avait parfois que de l'herbe
comme repas dit il
il craint que le rythme les arrivées ne
s'accélère sous une présidence byden ici
libéraux radio-canada dans le sud du
texas